what have you learned over the years in
terms of choosing people for your
production what do you go by do you
throw a little tests if you're
interviewing someone even if it's just
in the preliminary phases is this still
rolling are you rolling right now okay
little tests yeah um well in the I wrote
an article for film courage called ten
things they don't teach about actors in
film school and at this point I've
worked with so many actors and I've been
with so many performers that I I pick up
things faster than I can talk to people
right away I notice intuitively of
someone's speaking from their diaphragm
if they are changing their posture to
match mine or to match the tone of the
conversation because that implies a lot
of body training whether or not they're
matching the tone that I set which
implies a lot of voice training are they
speaking on my level and when my level
changes are they giving themselves the
freedom to take control of the
conversation how much are they
commanding the situation how much are
they controlling their space right away
I see those things so then it's just
practice I mean it's just from working
on stage and working in environment
people can do those things and then you
see someone who doesn't you run into an
actress in starbucks who walks up to you
seeing you passing a card up to
someone's like oh well I should be in
your show right away i'll i will know
the answer to that question you know and
and if someone has those tools that
means they have the fundamentals in
place and it's time to audition them and
see how they relate to the rest of the
cast and how they how they work with
everybody you know and on the production
decide it's the same but from a
different perspective and i don't have
as much experience working on production
teams i have about half the experience
that I have on stage so I'm not as quick
but I know a great shot when I see why
my mom was a photographer and I can sit
there and look and and it is also in
that case about how people work with you
the thing that was so great about me and
my DP giant arango is that we have a
really easy rapport his aesthetic is not
exactly the same as mine which means
we're always giving and taking which is
good because we wind up with more than
the sum of our parts in any given
production that we do together and at
the same time that happened
very quickly and very smoothly because
we give each other a hard time it looks
to everybody else like we're goofing off
but actually we're working you know and
that's something I noticed about him
right away we just that's that's that's
how we talk to each other and the fact
that we can reach a consensus so quickly
and the fact that we enjoy the same
things as we reach that consensus makes
us good collaborators because it seems
like you do process information at
lightning speed whereas a lot of people
may not how do you work with someone
that's slow or not that their intellect
is any less but just their processing
things slower how do you do that
patiently I got to get paid for it I
mean that's the answer I I at building a
building um an ensemble that has been a
life's work for me you know you just met
Gerard Mozilla it was one of my closest
collaborators I've known Gerard for six
or seven years at this point I think
maybe five I I'm terrible with dates a
long time most of the time I've been in
Los Angeles or at least it feels that
way you know and some of the other
collaborators I've worked with I've
known for even longer and it's just
about finding those people who challenge
me and who bring life to my work Gerard
right now is on his way reason he's not
sitting here you know working with us
right now it's because Danielle k jones
who is playing row and quantum theory is
in critical masses production of the
polish play and they're doing a staged
check-in for the audience today and she
is an intimidating actress she she is
incredibly smart she's also incredibly
quick and if I do not become a better
writer every single time I write a
screenplay I will lose her I know that I
can't interest her otherwise because she
will grow as fast as I can and maybe a
little faster so I almost need to find
cheats and ways to like skip ahead in my
development
you know what I'm saying I need to make
leaps that I don't know I can make which
is ultimately what you want in a
collaborative team and if we can
assemble which we have a group of five
or ten of these people then everything
constantly constantly constantly becomes
better why are we able to create such a
great movie in quantum theory even
though the budgets not that big and if
you read the screenplay it's a science
fiction movie without a lot of
production it's matter of fact and it is
realistic in its portrayal of the
technology that we're putting out there
it's not cheating the story you know I
mean this is not a ashlock production or
anything like that but the reason why
it's going to be entertaining despite
the fact that there is no trench run you
know no death star explosion sequence um
and the reason why people can depend on
it is because we have a group of
collaborators that are athletic to watch
watching them do their job is amazing
and engaging it engrosses you and that's
always been the foundation of great
storytelling
you